yeah you know it's not stopping movie
trailers they keep on coming so we have
a third trailer - Man of Steel this is
the trailer they're like all right other
trailers are coming out we need people
to think about Man of Steel it needs to
be first and foremost on their minds
yeah we're probably not going to forget
this trailer this trailer is pretty
sweet at the beginning of this new Man
of Steel trailer shows Krypton Krypton
is in bad shape it's getting its ass
kicked
it shows jor-el and Lara they're putting
little kal-el into a ship and Lara's
like being off cast I'll kill him Wow
I'll be a god to them I love the
fatherly concern right there the moms
like I'm so worried about my kid he's
like don't be it would be badass to be
him on that world they'll get cats out
of trees and take care of robbers not
like Zod's gonna be on that planet or
anything and it shows these heartfelt
moments between Jonathan Kent and Clark
Kent where he's like you're an alien
near the answer - are we alone in the
universe can I just keep pretending I'm
your son you want my son
you're like Dances with Wolves don't cry
you can make me grow this trailer shows
us what we already suspected about the
movie and that is that it's gonna show a
really human side to kal-el but show how
he has to step up to be this symbol of
hope not the dick bag he is and
injustice gods among us and in the
glimpses that we see we see things like
I mean I think it is the fortress of
solitude it has a metal door so I'm like
is the fortress of solitude a metal
fortress is the fortress of solitude a
ship all I know is it's a metal door and
a really cold looking place I suspect it
might be something related to the
fortress of solitude and when this
trailer Kicks onto full force and
Superman's down there you know he's
gathering his power and he shoots up and
the music starts
you're like yes I don't even miss that
Superman song you know when you found
out it wasn't going to have the
traditional Superman song in this movie
and you were like am I gonna miss that
no one misses that in this trailer so
awesome it's all epic you're like yes do
your job Superman
and we get to see a little more of saud
I mean two lines of Zod two scenes of
Zod but it at least answers the question
is that gonna be intense in this movie
is it gonna be a badass you believe your
son is safe apparently he's gonna be a
little more than intense Michael Shannon
even though he's being filmed in that
scene I don't know that he does he's
probably talking to his agent who first
told him I'm sorry you're you actually
didn't get the job of Zod you believe
your son is safe
okay in your mind
mr. Shannon your side a lot happens in
this trailer most of it is visual Zack
Snyder's a very visual director so this
trailer has like laser beams and rays of
light coming down on Superman he's
blocking it and [ __ ] this is a super
trailer of super Superman of Superman
who's a man who's also super from
Krypton who is Superman of Superman
ism's and I suspect this so I'm gonna
put this out into the universe in this
video so if I'm right about this you
guys can be like oh you were right about
that this monologue that Lois Lane's
doing for some he was a guardian angel
for others a ghost I never quite fit in
that's like the final wrap-up monologue
in the entire movie I hope not because I
don't want to watch the movie be like oh
I heard that in the trailer I'm just
saying it sounds like a wrap-up
monologue in a movie and I love the
final scene in this trailer she's like
why do you wear an S and he was like
it's not an S what's the S stand for
it's not an S on my world it means hope
and ass how misogynistic do you think I
am hey I named myself Superman and put
an S on my chest so you know it hold on
I'll be back I gotta kick the [ __ ] out
of Zod excuse me oh yeah in the face and
as cool as this trailer is really
hardcore fans of Superman are gonna be
like I don't like that I don't like that
I don't like that and fans are fans and
I understand people don't like the lore
being dict with like at the beginning
that's not a read Kryptonian son if the
movies good
I don't know that that'll matter and
kryptonite isn't used in this movie at
all but if you think about it kryptonite
was never used in Superman 2 which also
had Zod and plus kryptonite is stupid
that'd be an easy fix like kryptonite
you're in bad shape right Superman
also we took out Zod you know because of
that rock cloud story short this trailer
looks epic this trailer looks badass
this looks like the Superman movie that
we've wanted for years I can tell you
this if this Superman movie sucks
Superman movies are just it's not
happening so the new Man of Steel
trailer have you seen it what do you
think about it you think it looks badass
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you